part d find the total distance traveled
by the particle over the time interval
between time t equals zero and t equal
three or t zero is less than or equal to
t is less than or equal to three so
let's draw some axes here to just
make sure and you wouldn't obviously
have to do this if you were if you were
doing it under time pressure during the
actual ap exam but my point here is to
make sure that we all are understanding
what's going on so when t is equal to
zero where are we well they tell us x of
zero is zero so x is zero and y of 0 is
negative 4. so we're at the point
0 negative 4
0 negative 4. that's when t
is equal to 0. and in the last problem
we figured out what happens when t is
equal to 3. we figured out that x is at
21
x is at i'll say that's 21 right over
there x x of 3 is 21 and y of 3 was like
negative 3 point something so it puts us
right
over here so this is this is 21 and we
figured this out in the last problem i
think it was negative 3.226
and so this is what happens when t is
equal to 3. and between these points we
don't you know who knows what the path
is we could plot it if we wanted but it
might look something like this
so who knows what it does and we go like
that and so in part d right here they're
asking us what is the total distance
traveled or another way to think about
it is what is the length what is the
length of this
of this path
and
we could there is a formula for arc
length and if you know it you could just
apply it and it's not a bad thing to
know going into the ap exam if
especially if you're under time pressure
but i always forget what it is i'm
almost 35 now so i always like to
rederive it and there's always something
a little bit satisfying about that too
because we remind ourselves why the
formula works so let we could take a
little bit of a we could try to think
about well how do we figure out a little
bit of that arc length so actually let
me do a little other part i like this
part more so let's say how do you figure
out a little bit of that arc length
right over there
so a little bit of
let's say you have that little bit of an
arc length that i'm going to zoom in on
that
well you have a little bit of a small
change in x so let me draw you have a
small change in x over that arc length
which i've blown up so call that dx
and you have a small change in y as well
you have a small change in y
d y and we know from the pythagorean
theorem i mean this is if we get small
enough you can approximate this as just
the hypotenuse this is one this is the
base this is the height and this is the
hypotenuse and so this is going to be
especially if you get these small enough
a line is going to be a pretty you could
really approximate this arc by the
hypotenuse but right over here
right over here
i'll draw it right over there we know
what this is from the pythagorean
theorem this is going to be the square
root of dx squared plus
dy squared straight up from the
pythagorean theorem
now how do we write these as functions
of t
well we know
we know that dx dt is equal to x prime
is equal to x prime of t or if we treat
differentials kind of like numbers and
you can most of the time this is not
very rigorous but we know that dx is
equal to x prime
of t
dt
and we know that d y of t
we know or d y d t we know this is the
same thing as the derivative of y with
respect to t y prime of t multiply both
sides times d t you get d y
is equal to y prime of t
d t and all i'm doing here is i'm
essentially re-proving or rederiving the
arc length formula so we know that this
right over here is just a small little
arc length so we could call that we
could call that d
d i don't know d l or d a for a small
arc length
actually we don't have to worry about
what we have to call that right now but
this expression for that little very
small arc length right over there if i
rewrite it in terms of in terms of what
i have on in terms of this and this
would have on the right hand side and i
want to do that so i can get everything
in terms of t i get it is equal to the
square root of dx squared well dx
squared is the same thing as i'll do it
in that magenta color that is x prime of
t
x prime of t dt squared and then you
have plus
plus
d y squared and d y squared is just
this stuff y prime of t dt
squared and i i never make my radicals
big enough there you go and so this
little arc length can is is this right
over here and then you can actually
factor out a dt squared so this is going
to be equal to
this is equal to dt
squared
times
times x prime
x prime of t squared
plus i'll do this in green plus
y prime of t squared
and then of course you can factor out
the dt out of the radical sign now the
square root of dt squared is just dt so
all of this simplifies to i'll write it
in yellow this simplifies to this part
right over here is x prime of t
squared and this part over here is y
prime of t
squared and then we factor out the dt
we factor out the dt now this is all
just a way to derive what this little
small
d arc or this little small arc length is
but we don't want to find just a small
arc length we want to find we want to
sum over all of them
so we want to do is integrate the dts
take the infinite sum of these
infinitely small pieces right over here
these infinitely small arc lengths from
t is equal to 0
to t is equal to
3. and so now we just do it and so they
tell us what x prime of t is and what d
and what y prime of t is let me just
rewrite the expression this is going to
be equal to
the integral from 0 to 3
of
the square root i'll make my square root
nice and big here of x prime of t
squared the problem to give us what x
prime of t is it's 4t plus 1.
t plus one so it's four t
plus one squared
plus y prime of t
squared
plus
y prime of t squared the derivative of y
with respect to t is sine of t squared
so
sine
of t squared and we need to square that
as well
squared and then dt and this is not a
simple thing to find the anti-derivative
of but lucky for us we are allowed to
use our calculators in this part of the
ap exam
and so all you have to do at this point
we've already done really the hard work
is use this definite integral function
it's in our catalog right over here and
you can go straight to the f's
straight to the f's let me go page down
so there we go definite integral we need
to find the definite integral we have to
punch this into our calculator of the
square root of
and i'll write i'll write it as x's just
because the x button is much easier to
get to than trying to put a variable t
in there so the square root of
4 x
plus one
four x plus one squared
plus
plus
sine
sine of
x squared i'm just instead of writing a
t i'm writing an x here just to clarify
what i'm doing sine of x squared
and then we want to square that
squared let's see this so that closes
that parentheses and then i need to
close the radical parentheses right over
there i want to say that my variable of
integration is x i could have put t's
here and said my variable of integration
is t there's not no difference there and
then i'm going between 0
i'm going between 0 and 3.
and so
let's see let's let the calculator do
all the work here
and we get
it's taking a little time
we get 21.091
so this is equal to 21.00
and that's the entire arc length that's
the distance that this particle traveled